with the other souls of youtubers hyping
up code vain recently the
intersectionality of anime and Dark
Souls is upon us and there's no better
anime Souls game out right now than Momo
Dora reverie under the moonlight
Momo Dora is an indie Metroidvania title
that released in early 2016
it offers strategic combat a focus on
bosses and a healing checkpoint system
similar to that of the souls series
coupled with beautiful pixel art
graphics and a bit of anime Ness
to be fair definitely not as much as
code vein though reverie under the
moonlight is the fourth installment in
the momo Dora series but doesn't require
any knowledge or experience with the
previous games you play as Tahoe a leaf
wielding priestess who travels to the
kingdom of karst to end the source of a
darkness which is plaguing her land you
have two weapons a leaf which acts as
your sword and a bow this plus an
invincible role makes up the majority of
your combat tool similar to souls the
combat is responsive and satisfying it
has a consumable heal that were charges
at checkpoint markers like souls - in
this game
bells serve as bonfires restoring your
health and consumables saving your
progress and eventually allowing you to
warp between zones
however this mechanic isn't exactly a
one-to-one match as Souls Dark Souls
each death sends you back to a bonfire
without any of your souls of her
experience points but the world is
exactly as it is when you died if you
had opened up a shortcut right before
your death the shortcut would still be
open this can create some strategic
deaths in that if you sacrifice yourself
to open up a shortcut and die after
opening up the shortcut you will still
have made progress with that death but
in Momo Dora the bells act more like
traditional saves any progress you make
is voided by death if you don't ring a
bell opening a shortcut or defeating a
boss must be saved by ringing a bell if
you die before doing so you'll have to
redo the boss fight or reopen the
shortcut this takes away the ability of
a strategic death because any death will
reset your experience unless
you ring a bell so speaking of boss
fights they're one of the main focuses
of the game there are eight boss fights
in the game including one which is
repeated and an optional one there is
somewhat of a ninth but the fight is
kind of weird in the boss doesn't have a
health bar so I'm not including him in
the list but I think he counts as a boss
fight I don't know I did really enjoy
every boss fight in the game even the
repeated one each boss was stylistically
different in visuals and gameplay and
although some were a bit exploitable to
cheese they were all an engaging
challenge I felt each one was a
different fight each one was engaging
fun had their different mechanics even
the boss which had a hitbox of giant
boobs was a pretty fun fight that's the
anime side of the game showing overall
the difficulty was a bit lower than a
souls game but each fight ended with a
significant feeling of accomplishment
and achievement going through the game
the first time each boss did feel like a
significant challenge and subsequent
playthroughs allowed for more challenge
in trying to beat the balls without
getting hit as you get rewarded with a
special item for most of the bosses if
you beat them without taking any damage
so overall difficulty wise I'd say
there's a satisfying amount each boss
has its own zone and each zone matches
the thematic differences of the bosses
the game is only around 6 hours so
you're not spending too much time in
anyone's own but the time you do spend
allows you to really absorb the feeling
that was intended for each zone the
visuals and backgrounds are done
beautifully and really make the world
feel real and immersive I caught myself
disappointed in how much I was focusing
on the foreground and enemies because I
was missing out on some of the great
backgrounds which really absorbed me and
I would just sit in the stare for a
while at something kaho and the NPC's
were actually given a good amount of
expression even despite the fact that
there's semi basic sprites I was really
surprised by how much tone they often
expressed in their little animations and
facial expressions I totally got the
intended feeling when Kath give a bit of
an inquisitive and accusatory finger
point or whenever kaho gets a bit
confused at some other characters
questions the music and sound design
weren't quite as good as the visuals but
they were still pretty great the music
is generally pretty
with either no background music or like
tunes but it matches with the mood of
each zone really well soundtracks for
the bosses are well done and emotional
they definitely add to each foot and
while I didn't find any of them to be
horribly memorable I still really
enjoyed each one the sound effects often
match this nest Game Boy style that the
visuals harken back to a lot of the
attacks and explosions reminded me of
Gen 1 & 2 Pokemon attack sound effects
that I used to ear on my Game Boy which
was a really cool trip of nostalgia for
the world design captures a great
interconnectivity and exploration focus
that adds to the immersion the visuals
and sound setup the world is a blast to
sift and search through and I found
myself really enthralled with searching
and trying to figure out where I was the
world map helps you keep some amount of
bearings concerning your location so you
don't get totally lost what really makes
this work is that the game opens up
after the tutorial area and allows you
to choose where you want to go for
essentially all of the mid-game you need
four pieces of a crest to access the
final two areas but the order in which
you get these pieces is completely up to
you this means that there's a ton of
variety in the next four zones because
you get to decide which order they're
played in and each crispies gives you a
significant ability upgrade in
Metroidvania fashion like being able to
warp between bells or dodge midair this
gives a real sense of progression you'll
also receive smaller D upgrades either
through purchasing items finding secrets
or being rewarded for being bosses
without taking damage like I said before
these upgrades include things like
poison damage on your arrows or
defensive spells these items and the
crest pieces really let the gameplay
progress so that fighting the final boss
feels radically different than fighting
the first one although you still can
beat the final boss using only the tools
from the beginning of the game which
again allows for a significant player
choice you can either try and max out
find every item and use every tool in
your kit to beat the later bosses or you
can keep it very vanilla and use only a
couple upgrades or none at all and stick
to the same fighting style the whole
game an additional point on this side of
progression unlike souls there isn't a
leveling system in this game monies
which are this game's experience points
are only used to purchase items and the
only way to increase damage output is
through items or weapon
grades which are again item based you're
never spending any time in Maxine if
it's better to increase your health or
defense or something like that because
those things are only affected by item
pickups like vitality upgrades which you
find scattered throughout the world on
the characters and story it maintains a
soul's approach of bare-bones
explanations short NPC interactions and
subtle hints throughout the game
there isn't much development in most of
the characters as they are generally
pretty static having fairly unchanging
dialogue and remaining in the same place
one character I mentioned before cath
get some screen time and even helps out
in one of the boss fights but other than
her there's not much going on character
wise there are a couple small character
progressions as you explore through the
game that do add to the world but it's
nothing significant and there's not a
lot of significant character development
which is okay as the game doesn't make
it a priority but having more of that is
always nice the story is briefly
explained of player and item
descriptions give more exposition about
the world it isn't anything super deep
or narrative ly enthralling but the
small character stories help build a
fairly dark and somber game which
juxtaposes interestingly with Cohoes
overall happier demeanor these story and
characters help get the job done to
allow the gameplay visuals and sound to
sustain a really great game although the
game is pretty short it's quite a ride
it's only ten bucks and I'd say it's
very worth it as I've already gone
through the game about three times and
have had a great time in each play
through the exploration world
connectivity and strategic combat are
all done well enough to the point that
I'd say almost any souls fan would quite
enjoy this game and everything else
comes together to make this a great game
in its own right so that about ends up
most of my opinions on mode or reverie
under the moonlight I really recommend
it and thank you for watching the video
see you in the next one